in Dark genius Kerwin Swint profiles
roger ailes president of fox news
describing how mr. Ailes has transformed
both the modern presidential campaign
and television news the event hosted by
Barnes & Noble in Marietta Georgia is 40
minutes thank you thank you very much
thank you to the Barnes & Noble for
hosting the event I'd also like to say a
quick thank you to Phil Turner and the
fine folks at sterling publishing and
thank thank all of you for coming out on
a Saturday afternoon I appreciate it
and while I'm at it to like to thank as
somebody who helped me with some of the
research for the book Justin Wolff
thanks Justin
so why roger ailes why why write a book
on Roger Ailes
he's a fascinating character I always
knew he would make a good character
study for a book like this partly
because he's a real character and I was
right shortly after the book went to
press and late spring it was announced
that Roger Ailes will be inducted into
the broadcast and cable Hall of Fame
this fall which is indicative of the
impact he's made not only on our
political culture for a very long time
but on the news and broadcast industry
in general many people associate Roger
Ailes with Fox News and they're aware
that he started the network and the
tremendous success he's had there but a
lot of people are not aware of his 25
year history with Republican Party
politics from the 1960s to the 1990s and
I think in general he is is not as
well-known as it probably should be
considering the impact he's made on our
culture our politics and certainly our
our news culture in the book I compared
him to two people one of them is Forrest
Gump and the other is niccolò
machiavelli
that's kind of a strange combination but
I think it works on a number of levels
he reminds me of Forrest Gump in a way
because I can't think of another single
individual who has
around for some many of our key
political media events for so many
decades for example the Mike Douglas
show he was one of the original
executive producers of the Mike Douglas
show daytime television the Richard
Nixon campaign of 1968 the birth of the
new political rights in the 1970s the
Reagan re-election campaign in 1984 his
key role with the election campaign of
George Herbert Walker Bush Bush 41 in
1988 his role as an NBC News executive
in the 90s and then finally his
launching of Fox News and the tremendous
success he's had there so he's seen a
lot have been around for a lot of things
but unlike the mythical Forrest Gump who
was just along for the ride
of course Roger Ailes is a mover and a
shaker and someone making things happen
not just watching things happen so
that's the Forrest Gump aspect niccolò
machiavelli
there's probably not a better student of
makaveli on the face of the earth than
Roger Ailes and he has proved that time
and again with political calculations
and strategy that wins campaigns for his
clients whether they're in politics or
in media and so he has that that that
streak to him both in the political
world and the news business as a news
executive and we'll try to get to some
examples of that one of the themes of
the book is that Roger Ailes has been in
a unique position for 40 years to push
the country to the right both
politically culturally and in the news
business you know for example this is
the guy who taught Richard Nixon how to
walk and talk and imitate a human being
on television now at the time Nixon was
known for this cold sort of overbearing
persona he had which was a result of the
1960 debate with John Kennedy on
television and so he needed an image
makeover and he had run into a on the
Mike Douglas show and was so impressed
with him that you hired him to help him
make over his image and Roger Ailes did
this with a series of TV programs
called a man in the arena the man in the
arena programs they were broadcast a
certain cities around the country and
they were not all that different from a
Mike Douglas show you know they were pre
produced they were slickly packaged and
they were designed to showcase Richard
Nixon in a way that people had not seen
him before it was like relaunching a
product those are products relaunch and
they were very successful he was able to
show Nixon in a way that that showed his
warmth his sense of humor is
interactivity with the crowd and did
what a lot of people thought was
impossible and that was make Richard
Nixon look approachable inhuman and even
warm and helped him gain a new image
with the American people it was very
important in those programs to create
the right environment and Roger Ailes
has been very good at doing that
throughout his career making the right
environments getting the most out of his
performers in that case it was all about
making Nixon look warm and approachable
but he's done the same thing for other
political clients through the years and
he's very good at doing the same thing
in news production you know whether he's
working for a political candidate or a
news program host he's a master at
creating an environment that brings out
that person's strengths and he's on the
strattice career and it's one thing that
has made him so successful another
political achievement he is credited
with is helping the reagan reelection
campaign in 1984 after reagan's first
debate with walter mondale he didn't
look very good and the age issue came up
and the reagan campaign was sort of
concerned with how we're going to
recover from this this poor debate
performance how we're going to have
reagan reconnects you know with his
inner strength and by that time roger
ailes this is the early 80s he had
become known as a communications
specialist at communications guru he'd
been working with candidates for a while
he'd been working with corporate
professionals and helping them speak in
front of the cameras and make speeches
and he sort of had this there's air
about him of helping people perform
better
so Reagan's handlers put Reagan in a
room with Roger Ailes and ELLs worked
with him on reconnecting with who he is
you know and finding that inner inner
Reagan that inner Gipper
you know that he was so known on
television for communicating and just
help them reconnect with who he was and
his company's self-confidence came back
and in that second debate with Walter
Mondale he hit it out of the park
and the age issue was gone from the
campaign four years later Ailes was
involved in what is probably his
best-known political campaign effort and
that was his role as media consultant to
the George Bush 41 campaign this is 1988
Ailes along with the campaign manager
Lee Atwater systematically destroyed
Michael Dukakis the Democratic nominee
in 1988 through TV advertising and it
was a campaign that is considered by me
and my research and a lot of other
people who have looked at it around the
country as one of the most negative
political campaigns in American history
and it is held up as an example of how
to do negative campaigning in an
effective way you know where you really
take it to your opponent and you win and
they did that but a lot of people for a
lot of people the 88 campaign is defined
by the Willie Horton issue
you probably remember Willie Horton or
you've studied about it this escaped
convict from a Massachusetts president
who was used against Michael Dukakis any
ad a campaign in a way that brought up
all sorts of racial issues at the time
now I make it clear in the book that
Roger Ailes and the official Bush
campaign did not produce that famous or
infamous Willie Horton ad that was
produced by an independent group not
affiliated with the campaign and there's
no evidence linking the two however it's
well known that Lee Atwater and Roger
Ailes talked an awful lot about Willie
Horton that year all through the spring
into the summer
they made it an issue when talking to
reporters when talking to people in the
campaign and it was obviously something
they were interested in attacking
Dukakis on and that's what happened
later in the campaign when this
independent group came out with the ad
speculation has been that there was some
kind of coordination going on it's
always been the question if there was
coordination occurring between the Bush
campaign and this independent group
that's a violation of federal law
but there was never any evidence linking
them and there was never an official FEC
Federal Election Commission
investigation even though there was
evidence of direct contact between Roger
Ailes and at least one person who had
produced the ad for the independent
group but the Federal Election
Commission in receiving the evidence was
deadlocked three two three three
Democrats three Republicans and so there
was not enough votes there to approve an
official investigation and that's the
problem with the FEC of the Federal
Election Commission it's often a
toothless tiger and not a lot can get
done because of the party gridlock that
occurs and this is an example of that I
did manage to interview the the
gentleman who was the general counsel of
the Federal Election Commission at the
time who is still frustrated to this day
because he believes he's one of the
people that thinks there was evidence to
warrant an official investigation they
just simply weren't that able to get
there because of the political gridlock
now that 88 campaign as I said is known
as one of the most negative ever it's a
it's a famous campaign and it had
effects after the election was over in
Bush had won the lingering after-effects
of that really negative nasty campaign
affected the careers of all of the
people involved for George Bush it
soured a lot of the media and they went
after him particularly hard in his four
years in office for Lee Atwater it's one
of the things that he regretted when it
was over unfortunately he contracted
cancer and died several years after but
it was always one of the things that
he regretted and apologized for and for
Roger Ailes it made him as a consultant
almost too hot to handle it sort of
defined him in the American media and in
the subsequent campaigns he ran after 88
he was a target for all of the opponents
of his candidates they saw him coming
and some of the Democratic candidates he
was working against started running ads
against Roger Ailes you know he became
more famous than some of his political
clients and that's one of the things
that helps assure him out of elective
politics he had a series of very rough
campaigns he ran the mayoral campaign of
Rudy Giuliani in 1989 in New York City
and lost partly because of the baggage
of the very negative campaign tactics
that he was known for and another series
of elections in 1991 were tough for
Ailes and by the early 90s he decided to
get out of elective politics and go back
to television you know which is where he
got his start so he went back to
broadcasting knocked around doing
various kinds of media consulting in
early 90s
did some consulting work for syndicated
television shows for some Network TV
shows kept his hand a little bit in
politics at the same time and ended in
93 he was hired by NBC they were looking
for someone to help them turn around the
CNBC Network and so he became the
president of CNBC and did a bang-up job
he came up with creator then again
innovative programming that drew an
audience's their ratings went up and
most importantly their profitability
went up profits rose and a year and a
half two years that he was there but his
tenure at NBC didn't last as long as
most thought it would because around
that same time
NBC was getting into the cable news
business
they were looking at forming a
partnership with Microsoft which they
did in 19
six and MSNBC came into existence but
tough thing for roger ailes was that
MSNBC occupied some of the channels that
he had been operating on with CNBC and
he was sort of nudged aside there he
felt that he had lost some kind of power
struggle within NBC and and left in 1996
left the network not on very good terms
you know he felt that they owed him more
than that he felt that he wasn't treated
that well by NBC and there's lingering
feelings there it's it's still an issue
today it's still one of the things a lot
of people believe that feels the current
feud between Fox News and NBC you know
and if you have you know I've seen the
news accounts of this year there's an
ongoing feud between those two corporate
entities Fox News and NBC probably most
manifested by the on-air war going on
between Keith Olbermann of MSNBC and
Bill O'Reilly of Fox News two very
laid-back shy guys you know but you know
that's that's part and parcel of you
know some of the lingering feelings
there from Ailes days at NBC we left NBC
he went into the loving embrace of
Rupert Murdoch you know for my money one
of the best businessmen since the
British East India Company you know and
Rupert Murdoch is a brilliant guy he was
looking for an opportunity to launch a
news network that would cater to those
who believe that the mass media was too
liberal he was he was he was trying to
create a a market a niche for a market
that would cater to moderate to
conservative news and Roger Ailes when
he was available after he left NBC was
the perfect guy and Murdoch snapped him
but they had met earlier in the 90s when
Ailes was doing media consulting for
some of the programs owned by Fox
television so he knew very well who he
was why was Roger Ailes the perfect guy
to help Rupert
launched a conservative news network
hard the reason is that Roger Ailes had
been involved and something like this
before it wasn't his first time back in
the 1970s there was a national news
service called television news Inc TV in
this was a national news service started
by Joker's of the Coors beer fortune
Joker's is also a very well-known
contributor to right-wing political
groups Coors provided the money that
began the Heritage Foundation the the
premier conservative Republican think
tank that's involved in many of the
ongoing political debates we have today
he was involved in the launching of the
Free Congress foundation along with
conservative activist Paul Wyrick and so
he was involved in these right-wing
movements that were intended to help
push the country to the right and TV in
television news Inc was one of these
institutions and so Roger Ailes was
hired as one of his news directors by by
1974 and TVN was characterized by
ongoing battles between the management
and the reporters management many of
whom were affiliated with the Heritage
Foundation were constantly trying to get
the reporters to report the news in a
more conservative way in a more
politicized way and it was very
difficult to get them to do that there
were a lot of people fired they went
through several news directors and so he
hired Roger Ailes and Ailes
wasn't hired because he's a newsman he
wasn't hired because he's a journalist
in fact at the time one TVN staffer said
we know he's not a journalist we don't
like journalists we don't trust newsmen
he was hired because of his Republican
Party credentials and so at least on
that aspect of it they were very upfront
about why he was hired it's interesting
though because TV in at the time couched
what they were doing in a way that
sounds an awful lot like Fox News today
for example the TV and president told a
network executive that we
just report things down the middle and
we let the public decide if it's fair or
not which sounds eerily like one of the
main foxnews slogans today we report you
decide you know so there is a real
strong parallel there the problem for TV
in ultimately came down to money
profitability problems it was too
expensive to get the news out around the
country on videotape and to make the
profit they needed to make to keep it
going and and so it folded but if you
look at the parallels there for the
people who believe that Fox News is as
much a partisan political organization
as it is a news organization I think TV
n is a smoking gun that you can control
a direct line from t v-- n goals
practices to what goes on to fox news
today and is is part of the experience
that roger ailes gathered as a news
person and he doesn't like to talk about
t v-- in either not surprisingly he
wishes it would go away the best example
is a 2004 interview on c-span and when
the subject of t v-- n comes up he's a
little uncomfortable he keeps trying to
change the subject you know he really
just doesn't want to go there and and
talk about it
all right so fox news began in nineteen
ninety-six how did they do it how did
Roger Ailes and Rupert Murdoch and their
staff build such a ratings winner how do
they build create out of nothing such a
popular dynamic news organization that
the winds consistently in the ratings
these days part of the answer is talk
radio talk radio the audience for talk
radio is a big part of the base of the
viewing audience of Fox News you know
for years Republicans and conservatives
their biggest complaint was that the
Liberals to media in the media was too
liberal and talk radio became their
refuge it became the one place they
could go you know in Rush Limbaugh is
the best example where they had
something they felt comfortable with a
new source that catered more to their
political views that was more consistent
with how they saw the world
and that was the one place they felt
they could go until Fox News came along
and Fox News created a TV presence there
that catered to some of the same ideas
and some of the same preferences that
the audience for talk radio has so in
essence Fox News started off with a
built-in audience a built in base of
talk radio listeners and surveys have
shown that talk radio listeners strongly
far and away prefer Fox News as a source
for news than any other out there that
gets to the other part of how they've
been successful why they've been
successful at Fox News and that is a
real focus on entertainment Roger Ailes
believes that on television and this is
television after all you've got to
entertain them first right he thinks
traditional news reporting is boring
it's vanilla it's mundane he thinks the
real audience interest is in the
interaction of ideas discussions
free-flowing talks you know about
political issues and that's how he's
tried to program Fox News he's really
taken the talk radio format which takes
a mixed use of interactivity and makes
use of confrontation this free-flowing
discussion and that's sort of how he
models his TV programs and Fox News so
it's sort of like taking talk radio and
Penny get on in a TV environment his
first vice president for programming was
a man named Chet Collier who had
actually hired Roger Ailes out of
college to work on the Mike Douglas show
and Roger Ailes and Chet Collier set
about making a TV news product that was
very entertainment focused you know Chet
Collier was famous were saying you've
got to entertain him first and the news
the secondary you know and that's that's
the school thought he brought to the
whole idea and I think you can see that
in the way that they program their their
TV shows to really be you know
hard-hitting and confrontational and
check out for the little guy like Bill
O'Reilly calls all the folks gotta take
care of the folks you know there's a
talk radio sort of mentality at work
there
one of the chapters where I talk about
FoxNews I I call FoxNews a cross between
CNN and a Current Affair and that's sort
of the you know the talk show almost
tabloid like mentality that they have
used the Fox News that has been so
successful for them and has affected and
influenced a lot of other cable news
shows out there but Roger Ailes believes
very much in performance if you look at
the people he has brought to Fox News a
fair number of them come from what we
call tabloid television a Current Affair
Inside Edition where Bill O'Reilly is
known for hard copy and the others quite
a few veterans of those shows work at
Fox News and that's by design a stop by
accident Ailes appreciated the
performance abilities of these people as
he watched them as he came to know some
of them when he was doing media
consulting in the early 90s and he has
believed in trying to use an
entertainment format it's been very
successful for him and you know you can
watch a lot of programs and see that
sort of talk radio Current Affair sort
of tone to a lot of the programming at
Fox News it's worked it's worked very
well for him it's that mix the it's the
mix of confrontation discussion and
interactivity and entertainment that
allows them to slip in a political
message and and and guide the news in a
political direction which his audience
enjoys you know most of the people who
send in Fox News are more willing
accomplices than they are you know
people being duped you know as I said
with the talk radio kind of audience
they appreciate the kind of approach
that Fox News tax because it is
consistent with their beliefs and it
rings more true to them on the news one
of the differences between Fox News and
TV in which I was talking about earlier
and I mentioned that at TVN there were
constant battles between management and
reporters trying to get them to report
things in a more
conservative friendly direction well
they don't have that problem with Fox
News partly because the people that
they've hired from the beginning lean to
the political right to start with you
know it's one of the things that
characterizes Fox News you have people
there that are more politically
conservative and only all you've got to
do is look at the roster of people with
Fox News Sean Hannity Bill O'Reilly John
Gibson Brit Hume who used to work at ABC
News the morning crew they're all known
conservatives well what's wrong with
that what's wrong with it isn't that
just balancing out the the liberal
mentality of the other news networks and
newspapers well it might be one way to
look at it but it may not be the right
way to look at it for one thing there's
a couple reasons I think that for one
thing that's sort of surrendering to the
notion that it's okay to play politics
with the news you know that it's okay
for news organizations to take a
political direction and to report things
in a way that are politically oriented
you know and if you do that then we're
back to the days of the partisan press
where every political faction had their
own newspaper and and no one can really
believe anything they read yeah but the
other reason is Fox News does it
differently other news organizations
don't run that way I've interviewed a
lot of people at a lot of different
networks and news organizations and I'm
perfectly willing to admit that most
reporters are liberal they may shock
some of you but I don't think it's a
real debate anymore you know most
reporters lean Democrat that's who they
are as individuals that's one of the
reasons they go into journalism I feel
and I think the research backs up you
know and some news reporting does take a
liberal focus but those are personal
characteristics here those are the the
characteristics that these reporters
bring to the job they're not things that
are dictated to them or they are driven
by management the Fox News is different
at Fox it in my estimation from what
I've researched there is a systemic bias
there
on the part of management where
management does dictate a certain
political direction and that's different
from what the other news organizations
do it's intentional it's it's there and
everything they do and you can see the
real product of that come out in the
reporting I've got just a couple of
examples I want to read to you about
that about this sort of political
management of the news and this comes in
the form of a couple of memos that have
come from Fox News management to the new
staff okay I'm going to read you a
couple of them this one is in May 2003
from Fox Management to the new staff the
tax got passed last night by the Senate
the less than half of what Bush
originally proposed contains some
important victories for the
administration the DC Fox News crew will
parse the bill and explain how it will
fatten marginally your wallet the next
one here is from June 2003 President
Bush is doing something that few of his
predecessors dared undertake putting the
US case for Mideast peace to an Arab
summit it's a definitely skeptical crowd
that Bush faces his political courage
and tactical cunning are worth noting
and are reporting throughout the day
okay and one more this is from 2006 this
is when the Democratic Party took a
majority in the house on the Senate in
the November elections of 2006 let's be
on the lookout for any statements from
the Iraqi insurgents you must be
thrilled with the prospect of a
democratic-controlled Congress and then
it goes on to say in the house newly
empowered Dems will shed some fraternal
blood before settling in John Murtha
will challenge Steny Hoyer for the
leadership a former hawk versus a
political hack you know this is coming
from these executives to the new staff
suggesting how they they cover certain
political news stories you don't see
that kind of overt political
manipulation or management going on at
other networks or at other news
organizations for the most part
I interviewed the former president of
NBC News who assured me something like
that never happened at at NBC you know
so if you're wondering if there is
evidence for an overt bias there on the
part of Fox News there are this is
evidence you can find out there and pull
together along with the the long-term
track record of Roger Ailes himself and
trying to push the country to the rights
and and the various people that have
gone to work for Fox News and how
they've done that there are more recent
examples two of the things you can pull
out of Fox News coverage remember the
Obama fist-bump a few weeks ago you know
where he was going to give a major
speech and gave his wife Michelle a fist
bump there a correspondent of Fox News
found something sinister in that you
know and and the reporting was why can't
they just shake hands or hug I mean is
that some kind of terrorist handshake or
some kind of overt symbol of some kind
now that's over the top you know but
there are there are things like that you
can see consistently from month to month
on Fox News and another example that
I'll just close with is their recent
love affair with Hillary Clinton at Fox
News you know Hillary the Clintons have
been their nemesis forever but suddenly
this winter and spring Fox News finds
Hillary Clinton brave and full of
integrity and engaging and she's gotten
some of her best coverage this year from
Fox News I wonder why that could be
could it be that that kind of coverage
hurts the eventual nominee Barack Obama
maybe that's yeah that's another example
of something that is not quite
consistent with what you expect from a
news organization yeah so well that's an
overview the book goes on to deal with
the new Fox Business News Network which
is a competitor of CNBC it deals a lot
with Rupert Murdoch's News Corporation
and in various other issues of more
recent months but I'd be glad to take
questions or hear comments from some of
you all
you know people look I know people look
at FoxNews in different ways depending
on you know what your political party is
or how you see the news and some of you
may have heard of Roger Ailes more than
others but love to hear any questions
you have yes sir it is Fox News there's
a team of editors throughout the day
depending on what kind of story it is
they have a vice president of news who
is John moody and so he would be you
know the chief editor under Roger Ailes
direction but there are assignment desks
you know there's business news editors
there's lifestyle news editors a series
of them and some of them are more
politically oriented than others if the
Pentagon ever edited what Fox News
broadcast the Pentagon yeah well once it
ends up at Fox News the Pentagon doesn't
have an ability to edit anything they
may edit it before fox news gets it you
know which I guess maybe what you're
what you're saying they only give them
certain things and certain perspectives
but once fox news gets their hands on it
it's up to them as how to treat it
anyone else yeah do they have more
embedded reporters you mean in Iraq and
Afghanistan it's roughly equivalent one
it's not really a weakness but one
difference about Fox News is they don't
have as much of an international
presence as CNN does Fox News is much
more domestically oriented on America
whereas CNN has to the international
news all that but as far as covering
conflicts like that it's it's roughly
equal they have a fair number of
embedded reporters working in the field
yeah what was roger ailes comment on the
book himself his Fox News hasn't had a
comment yet
I contacted roger ailes office and and
asked if he would consent to be
interviewed and worked with me on the
book and his spokesperson got back to me
and you know Roger Ailes is a funny guy
he's got a sense of humor people loved
him who worked for him and he apparently
said he finds myself to be neither dark
nor genius and I would prefer not not to
work on on the project and that was my
fault I made the mistake of telling him
what the name of the book was yeah but
it wanted to be aboveboard and
completely honest and you know not try
to hide what I was doing I talked to a
ton of people in the news industry
learned a lot of things
fortunately anyone else any one of the
back well there are a couple other
things I could hit on if there are no
other questions or one may come to you
in a minute
some of the coverage this year about Fox
News with regard to Fox News as the
Benham has been about the aggressive
nature with which they defend themselves
you know and Fox has run a little bit
like a political organization you know
where they do opposition research and ad
rapid response
you know to criticism of them and I
guess that's a characteristic of someone
like Roger Ailes who made their career
in political campaigns but they have
running battles with other news
organizations with with certainly
reporters they apparently have a
blacklist of reporters that they never
talked to which I see in my mind now I
assume I'll make the black list this
year there's just a very there's almost
a bunker mentality they're a defensive
nosaka news as an organization that you
typically don't see in the news media
very often but it is a little bit like a
political campaign here's one more a
little snippet I'll read to you here
that sort of characterizes Roger Ailes
approach to everything
and this is when paula zahn former Fox
News correspondent left the network went
to CNN and there was a huge battle there
between Fox and CNN or lawsuits
threatened over her contract and all
this after threatening to sue Paula Zahn
and her agent when she left Fox for CNN
Roger Ailes put a movable FoxNews
billboard across from CNN's Atlanta
headquarters on the very day that Zahn
debuted her new CNN program I heard it
was available and that everyone who
walks in the building has to look at it
Bale said when a fox show would
outperform a CNN show Ailes will put
updated ratings numbers on the Billboard
to remind CNN Turner Broadcasting Jamie
Keller remembers that has a strange
experience it's not nice you're in the
news business it should be a higher
playing field kalanor said but everyone
dealing with Roger Ailes and Rupert
Murdoch should always remember they're
not so much in the news business as they
are in the winning business as his old
political campaign partner from the
1980s Lee Atwater once said of Ailes
Roger has two speeds attack and destroy
Ailes enters any competition as if it
were a political campaign that's his
nature and and that's how he runs
everything he does full-speed attack in
and destroy okay any final yes how did
they legally get away with claiming that
they're a journalistic news station when
they claim they're fair and balanced
when they're so obviously not how did
they get away with that well there's way
legally nothing to get away with I mean
you can say anything about yourself you
know and your product it doesn't have to
be necessarily true it's marketing it's
it's a part of it as branding Fox News
as an organization that plays it down
the middle in comparison to the to the
other these organizations and if they
get away with it by just just claiming
that they're in the news business and
and going full speed ahead you know and
from the standpoint of ratings it's hard
to argue with success I mean they're
doing it very well
drawing an audience and like I said that
audience to a large degree is already
built in and very supportive very loyal
of Fox News but as a newsroom is this
you can say really whatever you want
should I say they're an entertainment
organization more than a news
organization
truth and labeling to be an entertainer
he's not a journalist Fox News uh any
hobby whatever he wants is that we're a
news organization you know even though
it's very entertainment oriented you
know there approaches we do news we do
it better than the other guy you know
and and there's no truth and labeling
law like you see in the grocery store
and look at a jar of mayonnaise there's
no necessity to have those kinds of
facts on your news broadcast yes sir
broadcast networks packaged news they've
got so much time so much information to
put out there is there anything from the
standpoint of your known media that they
also in their own way move the direction
of news how they wanted to go by
packaging while packaging is important
for any product and television is all
about drawing ratings and I think that's
become even more important since Fox
News has built the audience they've
built because they have influenced other
news organizations to go in a similar
direction you know and I think with
based on cable news we tend to see more
programming like you see on Fox News you
know that it's slick that is that it's
package that is oriented on performance
and entertainment and it works it draws
ratings you know so I think they have
influenced other organizations to do
that there the other ones just aren't as
overtly political as Fox is yes and the
way they report things but this coming
election what might we see them do that
would show them supporting the
candidate a lot of it comes in who they
have on as guests what you tend to see
are commentators journalists that are
that come on a show like the Brit Hume
news program or like some of the other
more entertainment oriented programs
like Hannity and Colmes where the
conservators simply outnumber the ones
on the left but also you see it in the
kinds of questions that are asked the
kinds of statements that are put to some
of the guests on the programs or you
might see it in some of the ways that
guests or experts the interview are
identified or not identified you know
some accused Fox of having on pro
conservative experts or guests without
properly identifying who they work for
or what their affiliations are you know
those are sometimes hard to track down
but those are some of the things that
you might see this fall anyone else okay
well I've enjoyed talking about the book
I hope you enjoy reading it and B I'd
love to hear from any of you what you
think of it thanks very much for coming
[Applause]
Kerwin Swint teaches at Kennesaw State
University to learn more about the book
or to email the author visit mr. swint's
page at the college's website Kennesaw
edu what do you